welcome back to glam unfiltered hosted
by me josh smith and today we are joined
by
jacob montgomery yes
thank you so much for having me i really
appreciate it oh no we're excited to
have you
and you know what i'm just excited about
is
the broken hearts gallery what a film
it's
a little bit of joy a little bit of
escapism something we all need
right now but one of the things i loved
about it was it wasn't necessarily about
the romantic story between two
characters it was about
their own journey with themselves and
this idea
of love what is the idea of self-love
like for you as a person and what's your
journey
been like with it i think it's probably
relatively synonymous with what the
director presented me with
natalie uh who directed the film
basically when i
first met her she said i've you know
obviously had this film for a long time
i've had it written for a long time
and my biggest thing in my life is about
having a partner
whether that be male female whoever who
supports me in my endeavors and who
really really
really wants me to shine and blossom in
my own career in my own life
as an individual as well as in the
couple
right so for me that was the biggest
thing i wanted to target with this film
that was a big thing for me as well in
my own life you know for example with my
partner
um i just try and support her in her own
endeavors as much as i can
in her own career and in her choices
um and that for me was a big part of the
reason i think i was drawn to this film
yeah and i think we need more films like
this
that are kind of like you know the
traditional like chick flick team flick
kind of vibe
where we're actually showing people
positive
relationships because there's a lot of
like examples of gaslighting on tv
there's a lot of examples of stuff like
that that
mean that we need more representations
of relationships like this
do you think that's important as well
yeah i do think it's important i think
it's obviously
film and television they're all used as
outlets to
explore something that i think learning
needs to come from
the great thing is you're right this is
a really light film it's a beautiful
piece of escapism that's going to come
right off the tail end
of a lot of period of time in home
which i think is exciting and i also
think you're right there is this message
in there about supporting the ones that
you love
which i think is exciting and it is
it's coming from a a level of
i'm genuine you know when i tell you
obviously that i want to support the
other people in my life in their own
their own thing so that was directly
what attracted me to this
character i think also this character
isn't necessarily a traditionally like
uber masculine uber-like macho kind of
guy like
you know he's quite honest about his
feelings what is your
own relationship with this idea of
traditional masculinity
been like for you with stranger things
as well this idea of the archetypal
villain
or the bully or all this sort of stuff
and everything that i think was explored
in that show with my character was
fantastic because
i feel like when i when i was a kid i
was thinking i
suffer from sensitivity that was a thing
i talked a lot about
but then when i came of age it was like
that's a gift
you know to be a sensitive guy and i
always felt like when i was a kid or
this traditional archetypal idea of
masculinity
is someone that hides and shields their
emotions from the rest of the world
and i kind of when i came of age i
called
it on that a little bit was kind of like
i want to be a sensitive person and i
want to embrace that side of me
and also the characters that i play so
with
billy and stranger things it was making
that character everything but
this bully it was something someone that
was struggling with so much more
and i think that's why i wanted to do
such a big 180 with this character nick
broken hearts because i wanted to
explore a different world
a different idea but also the same
sensitivity and i think i am really
attracted to that
element in nick's character in the
broken arts gallery
because he is sensitive and he is very
aware of things
and i think that's why he has such a
powerful impact on lucy
and on her life um and i'm glad that
that was able to sort of shine through
in in her story as well when do you feel
like you
came of age i don't know i feel like
i've had multiple sort of moments in my
own personal life than multiple moments
in my career where i felt like i
summoned enough
courts but to push back against
whatever ideas i thought i was supposed
to be when i was a kid
so i feel like that has various
different iterations in my life i feel
like
leaving high school was one big step
leaving university was another big step
all these ideas of like
institutionalized life
um and then i think working enough uh in
my
career being lucky enough to work in my
career to get to a point where i was
really confident in myself
but you know your whole life you're
learning and you know i still struggle
with
self-confidence and all kinds of things
like that but
now i have enough grounding below me to
kind of
really own my personality
my choices all that sort of stuff and i
think for everyone that comes at
different ages
and if it had happened any differently
with me when i was a kid then
i wouldn't be the person you know that i
am so i'm thankful for all my
experiences
i mean your courage is going from
strength to strength so that's the
exciting part as well
and then you know stranger things has
been such an amazing success but
this idea of camaraderie i think is
something that's kind of gone for your
career on the different things you've
been on
um how much is that camaraderie and that
idea of teamwork helped you at different
times
i think it just increased more and more
like
you know when you come out of high
school and you go into drama school you
have to work with a body of people
get so much energy off the collaboration
collaborative sort of nature
and then you have time in isolation and
then you work with a film crew for
five weeks to six months and it's
collaborative and then when you
start to jump up in your career i guess
you get to interact with creatives you
love
so i feel like this idea of the
collaborative nature or
the ideology behind any film through
which is like a group a family
producing something or a story is
something that i've fallen more and more
in love with
coming from a childhood where i felt
kind of alone in my creativity
then it allows you to sort of block some
more when there's people around you who
are
really engaged and invested and
passionate about
creating and about hearing stories and
hearing different voices i think that's
the best thing as an actor you get to
wake up everything
read a new script dive into a new world
that something completely different to
last week
that's the best for me yeah how did you
feel alone
when you were growing up in that sense
alone
well i just i when i was younger i spoke
a lot about uh well recently i've spoken
about when i was younger being bullied a
lot so i think just that idea of
feeling so trapped in the high school
sort of setting in the primary school
setting
um and that idea i think individualizes
you
in a sense which is the antithetical
what you're talking about which is
collaboration you know what i mean
like even if to use the idea of sport
playing i never played sport as a kid
so there was never this idea of team
built into my
my mind my life my work right and so
when you're a bit of a loner it it is
literally
it's the opposite to when you get to
start working with
so many people like you're saying all
the amazing women behind the camera
on this particular project and all the
other people i get to work with in my
life
um it's so far the opposite
do you feel like you're doing this
career and when you have this success
do you feel like you're doing it for
that kid who was bullied back in the day
of course like to an extent and i also
think
we're talking about removing masks and
stuff i'm doing it for the younger
version of myself
selfishly as well right because i've
been working a lot on that in the break
and there's always sort of some
subset of ourselves that we repress
because it wasn't right at that time or
we weren't allowed to do that or people
didn't want us to be there
and i think when you press all that into
a ball
it becomes this raging energy but it
also becomes this powerful sort of dark
force and i think for me it's just
giving that
part of my childhood the power to be who
that person always wanted to be without
getting too kind of like matter about
the whole thing and coming at it from
like a psychological standpoint but i
think that's just definitely in my life
what i've tried to do
is kind of go here take that you know
and then you shed a layer
then you can kind of move on exploring
your story shed a layer you know i use
every role as a catholic
that's probably a selfish thing but i
didn't do do that
every time yeah i think that's what's
the power of acting isn't it the fact
you get to put your emotions from
someone else
and you can be like you go deal with
that now i can leave with that carrot to
move on
i mean it's also really amazing to hear
someone like you
talk this openly about the things you've
been through the struggles you've been
through and i think
if we had more people more men in the
public eye talking about this kind of
stuff then
it would help a lot of people to have
more open and honest conversations
totally yeah i think it needs to
this idea of of talking honestly
in that capacity that you're talking
about needs to become more of a regular
thing
but i think it's just like how do you
attack it on a bigger scale is something
i'm i'm yet to figure out and i always
talk to anyone openly like this like we
are
chatting candidly about it but i think
it's finding
where something went wrong in some part
of the system along the way
you know and try to sort of reroute and
go back to the sort of origin
and then we can figure it out and allow
all these things and values
and attitudes that we're talking about
to trickle into this idea of matthew
yeah and i think as long as we are
having these conversations
as long as even people are having them
with their friends like you're going to
dismantle
it by bit and that's the powerful thing
that's the power that anyone anyone
can do that in their own lives their
friends i think it's important for
everyone to remember that
yes no extremely i agree with you
completely well
it has been so interesting talking to
you today
i think you're great love the film um
keep doing what you're doing keep
slaying it
and hopefully your life super soon
thank you dude i appreciate it so much
and just stay safe over there i know
there's a lot of
cases still so hopefully you get some
respite and you can go out into the
community and do stuff and
um in the meantime i just i guess i hope
everyone enjoys the film and
it's gonna be great i think people are
gonna be buzzing for it
you